hi and welcome to episode number 51 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
hi I'm Francis Campo and I'm here with
my colleague mark Mendel hey Mark how
are you doing I am good thank you
friends ask how are you doing today
birgit a very happy to have someone from
our team that I really just assume we
had interviewed before but happens to be
we didn't get so we're having Sandeep
dinesh on the show he is a great
teammate and representative of the
developer advocate team and he's joining
us today yeah and we're gonna be talking
about about that game we're gonna be
talking about Simon Says which is
apparently something that you two work
together on building mixing IOT and
communities and stuff yeah that's pretty
accurate yeah I'll go with that that's a
good teaser people should listen yeah
it's a it is really fun and I personally
have seen what the demo what the game
looks like it is lots of fun yeah
otherwise one of my favorite talks yeah
and then at the end we'll have a
question of the week as always at this
time we don't know what happened so we
could have a mystery guest who knows who
knows who never go so before all of
these let's start with the cool things
of the week and this week as usual we
have more than one we actually have two
and the first one is a regarding I am so
we had an episode and I am identity and
access management yep what are the news
on this so one thing that's really cool
its new is an organizational resource
nice so it's a resource that sits above
projects which means then that you can
actually set owners for projects at an
organization level so say if you do
something like only set one person is
the owner for a project which you should
not do yeah and that person say leaves
that company you could get stuck so you
can set up organization owners so anyone
who's part of the organization level
that's great and it also means you can
do things like I've got people who
should be developers on projects so they
should then be able to access all the
developer resources say the developer
projects but maybe not certain other
projects that are for network admins or
completely other
yeah so I know that there's a very good
use case for this which is if you have
people managing only the finance side of
it being able to manage billing for all
the projects in organization that
totally makes sense yep so it makes if
you need to do things like this that is
probably the easiest way to do it now
yeah well check it out it'll cool then
the other one the other piece of news is
something that you are incredibly
excited about like you were jumping
around the studio a minute ago yeah I'm
a little excited um yeah okay I'm so
excited so if anyone doesn't need game
development unity is a very very popular
game engine and development environment
for people to build games in firebase
which we've had on the podcast more than
once literally well as we're recording
announced and launched the unity plugins
for firebase announced this is
particularly cool because previously
there was an open source plugin for just
a real-time database but now we've have
support for analytics authentication
invites and dynamic links cloud
messaging remote config and the
real-time database Wow so like you
basically have the full suite there it's
pretty awesome nice just for the people
doesn't know much what that what this
means what you develop community what
what do you think this will be exciting
for so I think this is exciting so
authentication so if you want standard
or Thoth indication for like github
twitter stuff like that and that's cute
just making that super super simple to
do analytics is free so you can plug in
firebase analytics and use them for as
much as you like real-time database yeah
so if you want to build like turn-based
game card based games stuff like that or
even just matchmaking and a lot of
companies use firebase format shaking
without having to worry about sukuk
communication or transport protocols or
anything like that Frey base is a great
back end as a service for doing that and
there's all sorts of other fun things
you can definitely do in there as well I
personally just with the author
authentication part of it I'm just happy
yeah like who wants right over with
handlers yeah that is awesome cool so I
think it's time to go talk to sandeep
and our other guest yourself which is me
yeah that's that yeah let's go talk to
myself I'm very happy to welcome today
Sandy Dinesh fell developer advocate
from the google klappa from Tim hi how
are you doing awesome finally happy to
be on the podcast
finally yes great to have you happy I've
been happy since this moment so we're
going to be talking about something
pretty cool that you both actually work
together right yep we cheese Simon Says
yeah could you could you tell a little
bit what is for for the people are not
American and I have not watched teenager
movies what is simon says yes so Simon
Says or Simon as it's called is a game
from the 70s or 80s not sure when the
same anymore lied 78 I think came out
yeah so it's pretty simple game you know
the box and it has four different
buttons with four different colors and
it'll light up one color and then to
memory game so you press that color and
then it lights up two colors and you
press those two colors and three and
then four and then as many as you can
until you lose right there's no winning
this game to the great holding this is
Ray game that you can only lose yeah it
was all like this is basically my
childhood before there were things like
Sega or Nintendo or anything I was like
okay red red yellow red yellow red red
yellow red blue yeah and so on and so
forth hours of entertainment yes cool so
why are we talking about it so um
Sandeep and I were talking at a
conference oh well about a year ago at
least now almost year ago called
ubiquity which was an IRC conference and
we kind of got pushed together into
building a project together and we came
up with this idea for Simon but we
wanted to make Simon multiplayer and
like massively scalable multiplayer yeah
so it's kind of interesting i think i
was gonna give an IOT talk and then you
were gonna give a containers talk yep
and then we're like let's do together
big talk together and then we said what
can we do with containers and IOT in
like real time and all this kind of buzz
worthy stuff can you like do something
that's kind of puts it all together
right yeah so we get came up with idea i
think actually you came up with the idea
i'll credit where credit's tier of
taking Simon Says and saying okay let's
make this playable over the Internet yep
so just understand before we get on how
you actually be on face how does one
play like what is the mechanics of the
game the multiplayer version yeah yeah
so let's say mean mark
playing okay right I will say green so
I'll pick the first color and i'll click
green now on marks device or screen it
will show up green and so now he presses
green and then he picks the next color
so it would be like green yellow right
exactly and then so ice and then your
comes to me and on my screen says green
yellow and then I can go green yellow
red and then goes mark screen and so we
just keep adding an additional color
until someone loses okay so it is it is
my it is online and there's many players
but in any given match there's only two
players yes cool okay so when I tell us
a little bit about how you build this
we're on google app iphone podcast so
i'm assuming that the cloud is involved
yeah a little bit little bit little bit
of it surprisingly a little bit so first
thing that we decided we were going to
do was talk about how we wanted this to
communicate like sandy have said
real-time was really important so if i
press the color red on my machine it
should show up read on his machine in
relatively real time yep we don't want
line to be an issue well the criteria do
we have any security was a big concern
for us obviously yeah King Simon Says is
the number one most hacked game if
that's yeah that's a big issue that's a
big issue a very big issue we also
wanted you know multiple devices to be
able to support Simon Says because
there's an IOT aspect to it so it has to
work on physical devices we wanted to
work on phones we want to work on a
computer has to work in the cloud it has
to work at all these different platforms
and kind of a seamless experience right
if I'm playing on the phone I should be
able to play someone on an IOT device I
shouldn't be locked into playing you
know only someone else on a phone right
so that's another big criteria for us
yeah I think I think it's actually kind
of interesting cuz i wanted to build
something on android because hardware
stuff terrifies me and i think i'm going
to set myself on fire whereas you wanted
to build like this crazy box with
buttons and wires and gangs so that is
interesting so you're using different
clients one is an IOT stuff which I
actually seen it looks like your normal
lunch bucket with buttons on top yeah so
that's actually a really long story
originally I went and bought a real
Simon Says from the 80s from you know
the store and I took it apart and i
soldered it and I put an Arduino in it
and it was so unreliable that I
eventually ended up drilling buttons
into it
because who knew that the old Simon Says
used actual buttons the new one uses
like these touch sensitive capacitive
things that are not reliable at all and
eventually turn to a lunchbox buttons
yes nice so one runs Android we have a
the other one is running no j/s actually
no Jas on what platform so we're
actually running an Arduino which runs C
code talking a protocol called fermata
which is basically you can send commands
up and down a serial port so USB and
then a computer runs the node.js code
and actually communicates with the
argument so they can be a raspberry pi
or a fully fledged laptop cool what are
the plans that we have they have like
iOS or so actually when we built this
thing we've had several team members
commit to it as well so not only is
there a java android one one of our
teammates met a built a java command
line client so you can interact with on
the command line nice and I think
Sandeep you built the road web one as
well right so we built one that works on
the web with the node server which is
pretty cool cool so the interesting
thing now it's okay so you have all of
these different customer all the
different different clients right that
are using different technologies how do
you make them communicate correctly what
how do you do this so it's probably also
worth noting that the backend server is
written in your favorite language I
didn't go oh sorry so yeah I also wrote
that the backend server to allow for all
the matchmaking sir putting players
together so that they could play games
together as well as the the game code
and of itself and these all talk
seamlessly with all the clients which
are pretty cool yep so I think you know
we had a few choices we could use web
sockets or firebase or things like that
but we ended up you know picking grp see
because it had the widest array of
support for all these clients without
having to deal with a bunch of hacks and
I think it was just very stable and I'm
surprisingly easy to like get it to all
work even though we're programming in
like four or five different languages
yeah we've done previous episodes 0 ng
RPC like the cool thing about GOP see if
you haven't listened to it is you write
this thing called a proto file which
defines the data that goes up and down
the stream and also the services so
basically these are pcs or procedure
calls that you can you can call and then
it generates a bunch of code for you
that's idiotic to the language that
you're writing and so whether it's no
or Java and what's really cool about
that is yes it's sandeep and i sat down
we were like all right how does this
work let's write a profile work out how
this thing works and then once we kind
of had the proto file we kind of just
split up and went off and built our
clients yeah well you know can't put in
a room for more than 20 minutes without
us killing each other okay yeah there's
going to be a hard visit to record yeah
so the next question is obviously since
you're using protocol buffers one of the
coolest things about protocol buffers is
that it actually uses HTTP too so it
makes things fast way faster is this
something that was going on does that
work in every single of the platforms
that you were using yeah I think we do
I've done demos where I've given this
over like 2g connections because you
know you're in the middle of somewhere
and you don't have a Wi-Fi connection to
your phone or something like that and
it's worked surprisingly well right
every time you press that button it goes
all the way to the server and a google
data center then comes all the way back
on another different internet connection
to the other device and it's almost
instantaneous which is pretty cool yeah
we actually we deliberately wrote it
that way to make life easier for us and
also because it's a cool demo to have it
like once you click a button for it to
light up it actually gets a light up
message so there's a button press
message that goes all the way back and
then a lot up message that comes comes
back again which is not to say you have
to do it that way but that's just how we
did it and yeah I've done similar things
where it's like yeah I've got a mobile
connection and I just push the button
and it comes back you know you're
talking hundreds of milliseconds if that
yeah i think the the gr pc
bi-directional streaming the Layton sees
very low which yeah Brand X for us and
it's a binary protocol so it's really
tiny going over the wire which makes
things great ever sending a few bites
right just that yeah close up let's talk
about that a little bit more because so
there's many ways you can do it so the
communication is as fast as possible and
the obvious one since you're having IOT
devices that do not necessarily have a
public IP could be the appalling but you
mentioned bi-directional streaming could
you talk a little bit about that yeah so
grp see one of the really cool things I
think that me and Mark were like a lot
is the bi-directional streaming so with
this you can send asynchronously from
the client to the server or from the
server to the client without having to
do polling or any of these typical very
compute heavy tasks right so it's very
very lightweight and the really cool
thing I think about
the bi-directional stream is once that
stream is open you don't have to sand
headers back and forth you just send the
raw data and because it's one canonical
stream it's easy it's really easy to go
against it no it was good no easy is
great no but I and I think it's like
what that is one of things I like about
your pc and it's so the flexibility that
you have there like you could just end
like synchronous RPC calls like unless I
send you some parameters you send me
back a response yay but then you can
stream data backwards and forwards yeah
and for something like this where we're
making a game like it's such a nice fit
oh yeah cool so so now we can understand
how all the clients work what about the
servers we said it was a running nodejs
no no servers sorry i was running ago i
mixing my stuff already yeah so i know
you love no chance i know i love it so
much almost as much as yeah so what what
about what platform was it running was
it a pending compute engine so we went
with a gke cool so container engine
container engine for a few reasons one
of which is gr pc is supported on
communities but it also allows us to
scale my sleep because containers and
cribben a tease it worked out really
well so it's actually worth noting like
we never actually sat down and we were
like oh there's a bug with dated like
going from like node to go or that was
never an issue like that never it was
always like oh there's something wrong
with my code or something nice yeah I
think it was I mean we're using what
Redis for the caching layer or the
persistence rights and that works
perfectly in Cooper Nettie's very easy
to scale and then our go code that you
wrote also you know can scale up and
down and it's very easy to use the TCP
load balancer on google cloud so the
geography connection just find server
and connects to it yeah for so you can
run five instances of this over 20
hundred two hundred whatever you like
cool so let's look a little bit about
the the rebus instances that you had how
many did you have did you have 10 3 demo
purposes I just run the one it was it
riding on a container yeah so I run it I
run it one as a container there's no
reason why you couldn't have a cluster
basically we use it for some persistence
and basically for endure container
communication is a public innocent
inside Redis
so if you've started a game so basically
if one player is connected to one
container one player is connected to
another container it allows that
information to flow between them say
this is what's happening and we could
have used you know data store or pub sub
or something like that but I think
another goal of this project was to keep
it 100% open source right so that was a
very important for us yeah um and that
worked that worked really really well
but yeah so you could run a huge Redis
cluster if you want I mean we keep it
really simple I don't think we're using
data volumes to keep it persistent
storage yeah that was the next was there
is gonna ask what happens if one of
those containers eyes yeah so right now
it resets yes completely like that's
that's like yeah for demo purposes is
fine but yeah if you were gonna run this
as a real game that would people would
play all the time you saw his data
volume here's an actual interesting fact
i checked the life of a cluster yeah and
it's pretty much been the same
containers running for the past 200 plus
days oh wow without any downtime and I
even upgraded the cluster from 12 to 14
and it was it was fine it was perfectly
just restarted the pods and it's all
fine that's it yeah that is for amazing
Wow so we've talked a little bit about
all the other easy things like grp see
is amazing and it makes it your life
easier like uber Nettie's makes it scale
very easily and containers developing
England's dinners so nice what what
about the high part what is what what is
something that you learn or something
that you wish you knew before you
started doing this so one interesting
thing is we used grp see before the 10
release um and it was much harder to use
back then I think a lot of bugs I mean I
talked to the team being like hey the
node.js package doesn't compile like oh
don't worry it'll compile next week I'm
like okay I'll wait until next week and
it compiled next week which is fine with
the one that oh it's much more stable so
I don't think people run into his
problems anymore but as a lot of fun you
know interacting with that team and
really hey look with a problem here and
then like they're immediately on it
which is nice experience yeah at the
time like installation of like proto see
you had to compiler for so us and all
this stuff now it's so much easier all
the time this episode comes out i will
have updated i think all the server code
to grp see one point oh so that'll be
good there's so much yeah there's so
much so much easier i can just download
a release of proto say for example is
the that's the tool you use to generate
code
more than not I'm trying to think of
other challenge I think one challenge
for me actually wrote a blog post about
this so when I was doing not usually do
develop me nowadays I do it in docker
because it makes a lot easier I mean
darling porter ç and compiling it and
all the stuff was simplified using
docker but because it was IOT I had
physical Hardware plugged into my mac
and so I've been doing a lot of IOT
development on Windows natively and it's
a lot it's a very nice experience on
windows install the driver can eyeball
works on mac i felt the USB drivers were
a little bit more flaky and then when
you add dogger to that mix man that was
fun so I had to do weird things like
expose the USB device and like oh well
protected mode and things like that and
as I wrote a blog post on how to do
arduino development on docker because
you have to use basically a privileged
mode to access the raw USB drivers right
and then you had a mounted into the
VirtualBox machine that's running linux
on your Mac that's running docker right
so it's like 10 steps to get it to work
but it was pretty interesting I think
that sounds incredibly interesting is
the word using oh yeah okay okay I think
I think for me it was working on the
server code I'd written like a huge
number of tests to get it to work right
but once you know as soon as you put
something production the best laid plans
and a lot of stuff but i think when i
first wrote it i didn't have as much
looking as I probably should have done
then went back and I loved everything
and it made things so much simpler to
actually see what was going on inside a
game and like because yeah you're
dealing with reading right one person
joins another person joins the third
person joins who gets match made why do
they get match made two things get go
funny I remember you made that little
mock for the server and as basically
when you join immediately win and I was
like I'm winning so much so I'm actually
curious about there's a talk that I'm
Vijayan gave it's about go down long
time ago and it was about how to do
matchmaking and go and and it is it is
kind of complicated like the way they do
it is like like juggling around with
channels which is beautifully to do but
it's kind of complicated I was curious
about how did you like how did you do it
was it hard to do it taking into account
that you have gr pc and so many
different connections going on its
rating
we lean on Redis oh cool so Redis has
got its got a list that you can
atomically push and pull from oh so you
just say give me the next to next one
yeah top one off and then is everyone
there now await and then look at this or
another one now yep cool yeah I know
really simple have you considered adding
a bot so I mean if you want to play
Simon Says with a bot I mean that's like
the most basic thing it would we have to
lose yeah well you never win yeah oh
yeah I just uh I mean you could add a
bot yeah and you could just cryptic be
another client right yeah just be
another client that way into thinking
this aiie pick a color and it has
infinite memory so like yeah can't
really lose to that be anxious but it'd
be a cool project though it'd be fun
yeah cool I think uh for any listeners
out there you want to build a button
give us a PR yeah maybe a button a
language we don't have yet constrain grp
see does support ten languages so that
would be honorable that made that big
very cool demo so you mentioned that the
the code is open source already yep yep
okay so we'll have a link to the repo in
the show notes obviously and what about
what is the cool things that you've
learned doing this not the things that
you were like oh man that was painful or
sorry that was interesting but more like
oh this is cool is there any anyone any
of those things that you remember so for
me I was my first IOT project with no DJ
s so using Johnny 5 I think it's a
really cool open source library if if
you're a JavaScript developer and you
want to mess with IOT you literally plug
in your Arduino and then you can write
JavaScript code to control your devices
instead of trying to write C so I wrote
see for a very long time I had a
start-up those doing IOT stuff and you
can shoot yourself in the foot so easily
write like buffer overflow and like out
of memory and you only have so much room
on those devices but with Johnny Five it
was just so nice to write IOT code in
JavaScript yeah is probably worth
mentioning that we interviewed long time
ago that was on februari third so super
long time ago we interviewed gent on
some another developer advocate from the
Google cloud platform podcast and not
from the Google cloud platform sorry
another pocket
and she also talked about 25 and how is
such a good way to get started doing iot
stuff so we have a link to that episode
to episode number 11 yep I think for me
actually I hadn't had a chance to play
with Redis before I've known a lot of
people a lot of people who have known
who have used it and been huge fans and
never had a chance to really rather
school and I was like this is really
cool yeah really just being able to
manipulate data structures on online or
basically via an API I don't have to
worry about how they work and be able to
access them from multiple places was
hugely hugely powerful and now like I
was talking about made matchmaking super
super simple yeah but for me one one of
my favorite things of of red is the fact
that you have very simple atomic
operation like a pen to the list which
sounds obvious but once you can actually
do that everything changes because you
don't need to fetch the value add one
put that book back making creates same
transaction stuff like that that is for
you guys really awesome yeah that's true
so one of the clients dimension was a
web client right and as far as I know
grp see doesn't work for web stuff
that's right yeah so that's actually
very interesting so the grp see does not
work on the web right so rocks on nodejs
JavaScript but not web JavaScript that's
I think it's because the browser's don't
expose the HTTP to functionality to
JavaScript yet that is pretty impressive
the the browsers are the one that does
for hcv 24 yeah yeah I mean so like the
JavaScript on the browsers don't support
like the native hd2 streaming and things
like that it's necessary for grp see so
the funny thing is we had a build a
gateway to kind of translate the tree
RPC calls into web sockets nice so it's
very simple I was like why you socket
i/o and I'm no Jas server and basically
whenever the G RPC call came in I just
converted to a web socket on socket i/o
send it to the front end that's
listening to that web socket and then
sending it back right so just kind of a
little gateway cool so so could I yo is
a library yeah so it's a library for
nodejs that makes WebSockets easier than
without it cool so you're running and
you're running the library as a
the standalone container or is it part
of the server or yeah so this is another
client right so I'm running it on my
local machine actually and then just
going to localhost to run the game and
you can easily run this on the web and
put it on the server I think we could
make it to another container we just
have a good yeah I'll be a good good
thing today actually we're really good
to do it would make sense otherwise if I
want to use it from my former browser I
need to run also I know Jess on your
machine yeah yeah oh wow okay ya know
there's best way to show up but that
that is an interesting thing the fact
that there's actually already a basic
day library that you say hey these grp
see on one side this well it's not so I
brought it myself okay um is that open
source to that is also open sourcing on
our repo and it kind of came up that was
part of the actual there was one
monolithic node client and that did both
command line it did arduino and did the
web and then when we open source it we
split it up into smaller projects which
is why we never got the idea of running
it in a container on Cooper Nettie's
which would make a lot of sense yeah
yeah I really thought you would say is
that oh yeah everyone think of a net is
it would make sense but ok cool ah so
we're kind of running out of time but is
there anything else any of topic that we
have not covered that you'd like to
mention I'll talk a little bit about
load balancing because it's a topic that
comes up with GOP see a lot the nice
thing about how we implemented this for
us is that we have short-lived games and
that's a single connection and once a
game is over it disconnects so there's
things you can do with load balancing
the GOP see that can be a little
complicated depending on what platform
you're on and how you do them but for us
it was very simple because we're like Oh
somebody's gonna play game once the game
is over they'll disconnect to the next
person who comes in or the next time
they want to play they reconnect again
and they can play a whole new game but
it may be a different container they're
not stuck on a single container because
you have a single connection so that is
interesting so what you're saying is
that if a container is running the the
game if that container died the
connection would disappear so the game
is interrupted yeah the game would
interrupt at that person whenever you
try to connect again you will never go
to the wrong pot you would just connect
to whatever part is running Chris Cooper
his humble stuff yeah yeah it connects
to whichever pod and then it would match
make you all over again and then you
would join a whole new game cool did you
did you ever consider trying to make it
so it's actually like even if a docker
container dies nothing bad happens is
that even doable in theory it was doable
you could store the data in Redis I kind
of wanted to make it as fast as possible
and so I kept a lot of it in memory yeah
but in theory you could do that too that
work as well my question was not only
about the above the data itself but also
bad were like how do you handle that
connection like that's trimming slightly
can you handle that trim across
different containers so right now the
way it works is that connection like it
actually the way the game is coded is
such that that connection declares like
that's that's the game and as long as
that connection is live it makes things
very simple ok in theory you could also
do something like with every request
sound like a game idea across the board
oh you're like yeah this is the game and
so if I'm attached to this this is the
message I'm sending that but it ended up
being simpler this way with a single
connection because you knew like if
there was something coming up and down
this particular bi-directional stream we
needed have to do with that game ok
otherwise in authentication gets a
little bit more tricky and there's a few
other issues is basically trading a
little bit of flexibility on the how
flexible is two errors and like go down
time yeah to the fact that it is super
comfortable to just use a little bit of
stay fulness there and everything is
much easier every go much easier cool
well thank you so much for taking the
time to tell me a little bit about Simon
Says and we'll definitely have a bunch
of shown of links on the show notes to
all the code and the block but you
mentioned and also I think you gave
talks about this right yeah we're both
done several multiple talks yeah yeah
well we'll have some of the talk so
people can have a look and see what the
what the game actually looks like which
is actually I really like the lunch box
with buttons I think it's very good yeah
funny the funniest thing just to end on
I think me and you mark I have only
given this talk together once it's true
right even though we built it together
yeah which is okay their life's work
yeah what will try to have a link to
that one then okay well thank you very
much thank you so much thank you well
thank you so much to us and deep and
well myself for
coming on the puck out today and talking
about Simon and grp see and communities
Oh Francis guy hope you learned a lot oh
yeah I understand I hope they learned a
lot it was very interesting I always
like asking questions to people that
know there are things and also it was
nice to talk to you so yeah no just
kidding it was it was very interesting
I'm I'm actually very interested on
taking out the the source code because
it is really cool the fact that you're
doing so many different languages and
just because you're using grp see like
the communication it the thought it
works yes pretty cool it's really really
cool alright um I think we guessed
coming for uh it might be outside now
hold on let's just have a look hey guys
hey you recording a podcast or something
in here ya gotta mind if I crash the
party just join awesome hey everybody
I'm Timothy Jordan yet they want the
door jump on the villa port road just
crashing our podcast it's what we do yep
how are you doing great i hear that you
guys have a question of the week and i
would like to ask that question may I
ease please go right ahead right okay so
on the developer show we've been talking
a lot about machine learning recently
and a lot of developers know that
tensorflow is a fast flexible and
scalable open-source machine learning
framework but what they don't all seem
to know is that you can train and run
tensorflow models on Google cloud
platform you tell us a little bit more
about the details yeah that's a great
question so I think that what you are
referring to is what we call the google
cloud machine learning platform planner
for short and basically it allows you to
train models on google cloud platform
infrastructure yeah and that's I think
really key because once you get into
machine learning pretty deeply your data
is so large and training takes so long
on your desktop at home that having a
scalable infrastructure trained on
becomes critical yea it is definitely
very very important if you're gonna
start training models so you can start
with either your own model choose one
from the tensorflow framework which is
open source and then you're gonna need
to train those models and no matter how
big the data you're using is you're
going to be able to do that on manage
and completely scalable infrastructure
on google cloud platform and then once
you're done you're going to be able to
serve those train models so you can do
predictions based on that with live
traffic again
cottonelle awesome it's also worth
noting though if like machine learning
isn't particularly your thing we have
pre-baked services that you can use so
we have the vision API speech natural
language processing and the translation
API these are rest api is that have
already had all the machine learning
training and like research all done for
you and they're at rest endpoint so if
you can call a rest endpoint from any
language you can use those things well I
will consider my question answered thank
you gentlemen thank you thank you I'll
let you get back to your regularly
scheduled podcast to that so yeah see
you guys so now I Timothy Jordan the
host of the developer show has left the
studio France asked where are you going
what are you doing is there just for
funk coming up I'm actually working on
the next just for [ __ ] which is going to
be it could be somehow really is
probably by the end of this week maybe
next one which is which is pretty cool
and maybe I will maybe go see you speak
this weekend yeah were you speaking
again so i will be at the Silicon Valley
dead fest down in map view cool this
weekend i'm doing funnily enough the
Simon Says talk interesting yep you
talking about jira pc in communities and
some fun IOT stuff yeah are you gonna
have your lunch box with buttons but
yeah we'll definitely have my lunch box
with buttons with that is awesome cool
well thank you so much today for not
only being the host but also the guest I
think I appreciate being here and talk
to you and to you all next week see you
all next week
you